On the radical left and they're
superficial view,
belief and value on the environment.
How has this influenced by their own raw
emotions inviting,
questionable,
immoral,
and dangerous actions despite good
intentions?
Well,
I don't really buy the whole good
intentions thing.
I mean,
I think that it's really hard to have
good intentions.
Like John the,
the question I just answered,
you know,
John said,
looking at myself honestly,
I'm deeply envious and resentful of
others happiness.
Well,
if you listen to the Lindsay shepherd
recording at Wilfrid laurier university
and you listen to the professors and
that the administrators,
I think that it's,
uh,
it's,
it's absurd to start with the
presupposition that they have good
intentions.
I don't think they have good intentions
at all.
So,
um,
but you know,
we could give the devil his due and say
that there are people on the left end of
the spectrum,
like,
like there are all parts of the spectrum
who are,
are trying to do good things,
but having good intentions and figuring
out how to do well in the world are our
good intentions are only the beginning.
And people are always influenced by raw
emotions and fuzzy thinking and it's
hard to think critically and it's hard
to plan strategically and it's hard to,
to intervene in the world in a way that
doesn't cause trouble,
which is partly why I recommend to
people that they start local,
you know,
you can't even trust your own good
intentions to some degree because you
have to test out what you do when you
have good intentions and see if it
actually produces the result that's
intended.
But I wouldn't make the case to begin
with that.
Um,
especially on the radical end of the
left,
I think it's unbelievably motivated by
resentment.